so tell me we're taller than it Smeagol  dragons  direwolves and three-eyed Ravens cannot  save you so are you looking forward to  rising again as the children of a cold  my problem I didn't hear nobody knows  what you said dude the Stefan Carter for  some repair the night King speech are  you looking forward to rising again as  the children a little cold  the great question we don't have much  choice in the matter do we ha ha ha not  is annoying like the night king of  California hey I'm from Philadelphia  sorry sorry if I made you sound like  you're from the valley I'm only out here  because of a Marine Corps that's why the  night Kings formidable he was in the  Marine Corps  thank you did you look incredible yeah  you do amount of beautiful color  [Applause]  you